He is the epitome of pure,
unadulterated evil.
The mastermind gallery with the
swastika on his forehead and the wild,
crazy look in his eyes.
He is responsible for one of the most
heinous crimes of all time controlling his
minions like puppeteer and
this week's biographics.
We're looking into the dark and
disturbing story of Charles Manson.
Okay.
Charles Mills Manson was born on November
the 12th 1934 to 16 year old Kathleen
Maddox and the 24 year old tranzians
labor known only as Colonel Scott.
Kathleen was a promiscuous teenager
who drank tea margins and money to fuel
their habits by selling her body.
The baby always known as new name Maddix
for the first few weeks of life until
his mother seemed to settle on Charlie.
He never knew his father.
He cleared out as soon as he
heard the Kathleen was pregnant.
Kathleen was too young,
too immature and unpredictable to
provide a stable environment for a young
child.
She appeared to have new
maternal instincts and would
leave the trial to fend
for himself while she went off on
one of our vendors as an adult.
Charlie often related to that.
His mother was once in a cafe with him
on her knee when the waitress offered to
buy the baby from her.
Kathleen's asking price once a pitcher
of beer and having consumed it,
she's simply walked out and
left Charlie to the woman.
According to Charlie,
has uncle took four days to
track him down and had him home.
When Charlie was six years old,
his mother and uncle decided
to rob a gas station.
They were both caught,
convicted and sent for five years
to Moundsville state prison.
The boy was putting into the cat of
is strictly religious grandparents,
but after a few months he went to live
with his aunt and uncle in West Virginia.
The environment's was very
different to many things.
Shawnee had previously known his arms
on like his sister was regimens is and
disciplines.
She was also strictly religious.
Her husband's bell was even more for
heaven's in his faith and his wife,
a strict disciplinarian.
He considered jolly to be a sissy.
On the first day of school,
he said the boy to class in a dress
in order to teach him how to fight.
Charlie's seem to adapt it to this very
different kind of life and actually grew
to enjoy his new regimented routine.
The two years between six and eight would
prove to be some of the most stable of
his young life,
but then his mother was released from
prison and immediately took him back.
Kathleen was more unstable than ever.
She preferred a life of promiscuity
and alcohol abuse to baton all domestic
city,
constantly in trouble with the law
ends with no money for food and board.
They constantly moved around the
Midwest or the age of nine trolley.
He dropped out of school.
The transient life that he was forced
to live shapes the type of boy that
Charlie would become.
He kept to himself living his
life through his imagination.
He was constantly watching,
taking things in and
dreaming of a future free of.
There's no hope.
Mother.
He also learns how to become
a very accomplished thief
as age nine Charlene was
caught stealing and sent to reform school.
Three years later he was caught again.
This time he was packed off to the Jib
old school for boys in Indiana before he
was taken away.
Kathleen promise to to visit him often.
Of course they,
she never did.
Just 10 months into his incarceration,
jolly escapes,
he robbed a grocery store to get
some money and went that run out.
He stole other things including a bicycle.
He got caught in the act of making off
with the bike and soon found himself back
and confinements.
This time he was sent to
Indiana juvenile center.
That's after just two days.
He stole some cutters and
it's free and not any himself.
There's 30 other boys
this time he escaped.
Young Fella installed motorbike bike,
but rather a car,
but the 13 year old could hardly see over
the steering wheel and was apprehended
within hours of his escape.
When he ended up in juvenile court,
he was surprised to see his mother.
His spirits were dashed.
However,
when she testified that she would not
take him out of the somewhat sympathetic
judge since Charlie to
Father Flanagan's boys town,
but the state here,
it was almost a short as
his last incarceration.
After just four days,
he ran off with another young offender,
Blackie Nelson.
They stole a car which
they subsequently crashed.
Still they made that weighs
in the hammock black.
He's uncle Lee,
World War II veteran,
and an underworld figure who gave the
young hoodlums free board and food in
exchange for the proceeds from armed
robberies that he happened commit during
that third robbery.
The two boys were caught this time at
Shawnee was sent to the Indiana school for
boys in Plainfield.
Yeah,
he stayed for three years.
Charlie would lead to claim that his
small statue led him to being constantly
raped and sodomized by other inmates
as well as by the school employees.
He also recalls that he was constantly
picked on by the gods who would
continually find fault with him beating
him with leather straps and toured and
clubs.
Okay.
One night after being gang
raped by a group of older boys.
He beat one of his attack is do just
short of the point of death with an iron
bar as the boy lay sleeping.
Charlie then placed the iron bar under
the banner of one of the other attackers
successfully implicating
him in the attack.
Johnny was exhibiting a trait that
would characterize his personality as an
adult.
This was that he would hold his anger in
for a time only for it to explode later
in an orgy of violence.
Over the three years
he spent at Plainfield,
Charlie escapes no less than 18 times.
He was returned every time though
and in March of 1951 his sentence was
increased and he was sent it to
a minimum security institution.
This was the national training
school for boys in Washington DC.
Here things were very different to
what Charlie had known at Plainfield.
The facility was well run.
The boys were treated well and say genuine
focus was placed on rehabilitation.
Charlie liked at that,
but he had to no interest
in being rehabilitated.
He'd do his time,
but then it would get back out to the
life of crime that he knew was waiting for
him.
At around the age of 15 Charlene
was given a psychiatric assessments.
He was found to be aggressive,
antisocial and illiteracy.
The case worker reported that the boy
was severely emotionally traumatized and
in serious need of psychiatric treatments.
It was also noted that he has a
higher than normal aptitude for music.
Well,
I would say with the 24th of 1951 Charlie
was transferred to the national bridge
on a camp in Petersburg,
Virginia.
Three months later,
just weeks before his parole hearing,
he sodomized and other inmates while
holding a razor blade to his neck.
He was reclassified as extremely
dangerous and transfer to a tougher high
security facility.
The federal reformatory at Petersburg,
Virginia.
After seven months of
the federal reformatory,
Charlie had racks up
eight major violations.
He was classified as
defined the homosexual,
dangerous and safe only under
supervision with assaultive tendencies.
Towards the end of 1952 he was sentenced
to a higher security facility still.
That's at the surprise of everybody.
He transformed into a model prisoner.
He took lessons in reading and math and
began working in the vehicle maintenance
department.
On January the first 1954 he was
given a Meritus service award for his
scholastic achievements.
His application to his studies and
does a parent change of attitude led to
Charlie being paroled.
On May the eighth 1954 he was put
into the care of his aunt and uncle,
but within a month of the now 19 year
old was back living with his mother
herself.
Recently released from prison.
Yeah.
Six months after his release,
Charlie married a waitress by
the name of Rosa Gene Willis.
Shortly thereafter,
I Sung Charles Manson.
Junior was born.
Charlie worked as a low income job or
augmenting his pay by stealing cars.
He used one of those stolen cars to me
of his wife and baby to Los Angeles.
The car had been taken from Ohio and the
authorities were able to track it down.
It was charged with a federal crime
for taking the car across state lines.
He was given five years probation,
but when he failed to show
up to a subsequent hearing,
he was arrested with
his probation revoked.
Charlie was San for three years to the
prison on Terminal Island in San Pedro,
California.
After being there a few months,
he was informed that his wife
was living with another man.
Two years later,
she obtained a decree after force.
In September of 1958 Charlie was
released on five years of parole.
He was now extending his criminal
earning potential by becoming a pimp.
He had a 16 year old girl working for him.
Over the next year.
He runs around California and New Mexico
committing crimes and repeatedly coming
across the law.
In June of 1960 you fled the taxes
with a California warrants out for his
arrest.
When one of his girls was
arrested for prostitution,
he was picked up and returned to Los
Angeles to face a 10 year sentence for
cashing a forged treasury check.
At the age of 26 he was sent to the
u s penitentiary as Mcneil Islands,
Washington.
While serving his sentence,
he learns to play.
The guitar runs,
became interested in
Scientology during his time.
That's Mcneil Island.
He also became obsessed with the Beatles.
Charlie has an inflated appreciation
of his own musical talents,
claiming that he would with the right
backing and training be even bigger than
the Beatles.
Shawnee became friends with an
inmate by the name of Alvin carpets.
This former public enemy number one
was a former member of the infamous Ma
Barker gang.
He told Charlie how to
play the steel guitar.
This further fueled his musical obsession
and in 1966 Charlie's prison record
knows is that he spent most of
his free time writing songs.
It cumulating 80 or 90 of
them in a single competence.
Later commented on the Charlie
that he knew at that time.
He recalled that Manson was a
master manipulator of other people,
prison authorities.
Also,
he noted that he had a tremendous
drive to call attention to himself.
In June of 1966 Charlie was sent
once against Tom and Leiland.
This time in preparation
for early release.
When the day arrived on March the 21st
1967 he had spent more than half of his
32 years behind bars.
He requested that the
authorities let him stay in jail,
but he was told that he had to leave
and so it was that the five foot nothing
drifter with the penetrating stare and
gift of the Gab Wanders into the height
Ashbury district of San Francisco with
$35 in his pocket and to new plans
except for a desire to make it big in the
music business.
Jolly moves into an apartment in
Berkeley and made money by panhandling.
Before long he had gotten
to know a 23 year olds,
assistant librarian at UC
Berkeley named Mary Brunner.
He quickly one a rover and moved into
our apartments and Bronto came under
Charlie's felons.
He convinced her to widen out the home.
Within a few months there were
18 young women living with them.
Charlie introduced Mary and the other
girls to drugs and before long Mary had
quit her job and become a
devoted follower of Manson.
The family was beginning to take shape
with his female entourage and his guitar.
Charlie merged perfectly into the heady
culture that was then in full bloom in
San Francisco.
He refined his role as a spiritual
master or guru as a prophet.
He used mind control techniques to
get girls to do whatever he wants it.
Most of the girls he gathered around
him came from troubled backgrounds and
suffered from insecurities that
left them directly opens a Charlie's
manipulations as well as breaking down
their inhibitions with mind control
techniques.
He used LSD and amphetamines to
control his ever expanding Horam.
After about nine months living
in and around San Francisco,
Charlie began to to spanner of the place.
They're tired.
He asserted become to overrun with
African Americans and crime was rampant.
Of course,
that family were doing their best
to add to those crimes statistics.
They stole credit cards and used
counterfeit money to get what they needed.
They also stole the big yellow
bus and painted it black
oh
Johnny and just follow his took to
traveling by bus down the California
coastline as far as Mexico and Texas
partying and committing more crimes after
18 months.
So extended travel.
They finally settled in Topanga Canyon
near Los Angeles in a two story house.
It was here that Ciani began gathering
some male members to the family.
The first was a teenager
named Bobby Beausoleil.
Lyle who turned up one night
for a party and then stayed on.
There's Charlie's righthand man,
but we had been staying
with his music teacher,
Gary Hinman,
not far from the Manson home.
What were you recruited
and 18 year olds and m's,
Leslie Van,
who teens or the family in
June of 1968 around that time,
Charlie and some of the girls traveled
to Los Angeles where they met up with a
record executive at Universal Studios
Format Jl friends feel Calvin had arranged
the meeting.
This was Charlie's entry into the rich
jet crowd and he turns on all of his
charm to make a good impression.
Seeing the family were rubbing shoulders
with the rich and famous it posh
parties in the Hollywood hills and the
late spring of 1968 beach boys drama.
Dennis Wilson was driving away from Malibu
beach when he happened to pick up two
hitchhikers.
The girls were part of the Manson family
and they quickly agreed to go back to
his Beverly hills home.
The three made love that afternoon and
Wilson left for a recording session
promising to return later to take up
where they left off when Wilson written
time in the early hours
of the following morning,
he was surprised to see that a
full scale party was underway.
He was greeted in the driveway by a
short man with a scraggly beard who
approached him,
dropped to his knees,
and began kissing his feet.
The girls who Dennis had met earlier,
I came running out declaring this is
the guy that we were telling you about.
This is Charlie.
Inside his home,
Wilson found a 12 more women,
most of them topless lying
around and smoking pot.
Manson told him,
but the girls were all
there for Wilson's pleasure.
Wilson was impressed with the sway
that Charlie held over the women.
He welcomes the family with open arms
and his home became the regular venue for
Charlie orchestrated orgies.
Wilson calls and Manson the wizard
and began inviting influential showbiz
friends do come and meet him.
Dennis also allowed Charlie
do you anything you wanted,
it's Ferrari or a Rolls Royce and all
the food and drink and drugs that he or
his group he's wanted.
Eventually Wilson's manager became fed
up with the influence and expense that
Manson was having on his clients and
Charlie and the girls were ordered out of
the mansion rim as well.
Also spreading of the children of the
rich and famous being given drugs and
having sex.
I'm just [inaudible].
Suddenly the door do the
Hollywood elite lifestyle.
It would slam shut.
Charlie's planned for music.
Korea was also shut down.
This coolest a familiar
buildup of jealousy,
anger,
and rage that would inevitably
find expression in violence.
Madison managed to convince the owner
of a former western movie set the spawn.
Raj and chance would not far from Topanga
Canyon to allow the family to live in
the abandoned his property.
The family now moved to the ranch,
getting by by stealing and scavenging.
Jolly took to quoting the Bible.
It's family members as they gathered
round a bonfire during the evenings.
He also interpreted Beatle songs
explaining that the lyrics were directed
towards them.
He was obsessed with one
song helter skelter telling
his followers that the song
in visions and apocalypse brought on
by a race war of blacks killing whites.
The blacks would when he said,
but it would then sounds a
Manson to lead the new world
for Charlie.
However,
the revolution was taking too long.
He wants it to happen immediately.
He began preparing family members for a
series of actions that would precipitate
the black uprising.
The first step would be to release an
album of music that would contain subtle
messages that would ferment
the black revolution.
On May the eighth 1969 Terry Melcher
reproducer producer who had met Shawnee
through Dennis Wilson arrived at spawn
ranch to listen to Charlie and it's the
girl sing Melcher.
It made promises but never
followed through on them.
On the 25th of July,
1969 John old did Bobby beausoleil and
it's to women's of the home of Gary
Hinzman.
The music teacher Bobby
used to live with Manson,
had heard that Hinzman had
inherited $20,000 and he wanted us.
Hinzman refused to hand over the money.
Charlie was cools and soon
arrived off to screening as him.
Shawnee pulled out a
sword and cut off his ear.
Charlie then left with instructions.
Do you get the money or kill the man?
After three days,
Bobby stabbed his former teacher to death.
Before leaving.
He and the girls write the words
political piggy on the wall along with a
panther pour in red to lay the blame
on the Black Panther movements.
Bobby Beausoleil was arrested for murder
on August the sixth 1969 after being
core to driving around in Hyndman's car
Manson was now ready to get his revenge
on Terry Melcher,
the record producer who had let him down
on the evening of the 8th of August.
He directed followers tax Watson,
Linda Kasabian,
Susan Atkins,
and Patricia Crenn Winkle.
To the house where he believed Melcher
was living with instructions to totally
destroy everyone in is making
it as gruesome as possible.
The house was located at one
zero zero five zero clo drive,
but Melchert didn't live there anymore.
It was now occupied by a famous director,
Roman Polanski and his beautiful
eight month pregnant wife,
Sharon Tate there.
Nice Polanski was in
Europe on a film project.
His wife was entertaining guests
that the property hairdresser,
Jay Sebring,
screenwriter of Voya tag
fry Koski and coffee empire.
Irs Abigail Foga,
I think at the property around midnight,
Watson climbed to telephone
pole near the Gazans,
cut the phone line.
The car was then back to the bottom of
a hill that led to the house and the
murder team walked up to find the victims.
Watson thought the gate
might be electrified,
so he ends.
The girls climbed a brushing
embankments and get onto the grounds.
Just then car headlights came up from
further up on the property ordering the
women's or lie down in the bushes.
Watson approach,
the Vehicle Lens leveled is 22
caliber rifle at the driver.
That was 18 year old.
Steven parents,
what's in first slashed him with a knife
and then shot him four times in the
chest.
Watson,
some ordered Linda Kasabian to
keep watch down by the gate.
He and the other two women
made their way into the house.
The occupants were quickly gathered
together in the lounge when asked by for
Koski who they were.
Once in replied,
I'm the devil and I'm here
to do the devil's work.
What's in then began to
Tie v heavily pregnant.
Sharon Tate and JC bring together
by their necks with rope,
had brought and slung over a beam.
Went Sebring,
protested over the rough
handling of Sharon Watson,
shot him and then stamped him seven times.
Meanwhile for cal skate again
struggling with Susan Atkins,
he repeatedly stabbed him in
the legs and torso still free.
Cal Skate managed to
get to the front door.
Seeing this Watson rushed after him
meeting up with him on the porch and
smashing his head with gun bus before
shooting him twice or they go for,
had managed to escape out toms the art.
She was chased by Patricia Cranney
Winkle who tackled her and stabbed her to
death.
The only remaining victim was now Sharon
Tate as she lay on the lounge room
floor with a wrap arounds and actually
beg to be able to live long enough to
have a child,
but a police were ignored and either
Watkins or Atkins stabbed her repeatedly,
including in the abdomen until both
she and her unborn baby with debt,
remembering Manson's instructions
to leave a sign on the walls.
Atkins wrote the word
pig with Tate's blood.
The very next day the family struck
again this time the victims were Leno and
Rosemarie Lablanca unhappy
with the messiness of the
previous night's killings.
This time Charlie went with the
group to show them how it was done.
Different accounts have
been given the balance,
the exact happenings that night,
but we do know that Manson was in the
house and that he orchestrated the tying
up of the couple.
He then left with the orders that the
couple be killed before leaving the words
war.
Rise.
Death to pigs and helter skelter were
written with the blood of the victims on
the walls and the refrigerator door.
The murders caused a huge panic.
Hollywood's the pressure was now
on to solve the heinous crimes.
The police got nowhere until they finally
linked to the Hinman murder to the
tailor blanket killings.
They knew that Bobby Beausoleil Ale
had lived with a group of hippies.
It spawn ranch,
so they decided to pay
the ranch and visit.
Bobby's girlfriends had told
police that Charlie Manson,
they had bigger euro,
had ordered the killing of Henman.
Still,
there was no evidence linking
the group to the later murders.
Then in October 24 months
and family members,
including Charlie,
were arrested on charges of
arson and his grand thefts.
Seasoned Atkins was also
taken into custody and it
was she who fast to began to
spill the beans.
She brags to a cellmate of
hours killing Sharon Tate,
giving a detailed accounts
since implicating Charlie
as the mastermind's about.
At the same time,
police interviewed a
member of the streets,
Satan's motorcycle gang,
who was in Madison acquaintance.
He told them the Manson had recently
been bragging about knocking off five
people.
The first piece of physical evidence was
the fingerprints of Patricia ran Winkle
that was found on Sharon
Tate's bedroom door.
When other pieces of physical
evidence were recovered,
the police were ready to send the case
to court Manson and the four people who
had committed the Tate labianca murders
were found guilty and sentenced to
death.
These penalties,
however they would never be imposed.
In 1972 the California Supreme Court
declared the state's death penalty law
unconstitutional.
Manson's death sentence was
commuted to life imprisonment.
Charles Manson died on November the
19th 2017 of cardiac arrest having spent
nearly 50 years behind bars for his
orchestrating of the crimes that took the
worlds in 1969 he was 83 years of age,
so I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel
for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday.
Also I've got another channel and
it's called top tens on that channel.
As you might guess from the name.
We look at all sorts of
interesting top tens.
You can check it out through
the link on the screen now,
but if you're looking at
something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the
archives or a top tens video over there
on the right?
And as always,
thank you for watching.